today we're talking about data stream
artifact registry and api design i'm agv
and welcome to this week in cloud where
we serve you the lowest latency news
on top of all the data announcements
from last week we've also launched data
stream and preview data stream is a
serverless change data capture
and replication service that allows you
to synchronize data across
databases storage and applications
creating a stream captures data changes
from sources like
oracle and mysql and stores is in cloud
storage
where you can use dataflow to transform
the data to however you need
try it out today and stay tuned for even
more supported data sources soon
as a developer you need a secure place
to store all your stuff
container images of course but also
language packages that can enable code
reuse across
multiple applications today we're
pleased to announce support for
node.js python and java repositories for
artifact registry and preview
now you can not only secure and
distribute container images but also
manage and secure your
other software artifacts if you're
looking to develop
run and secure applications across your
hybrid and multi-cloud environments
look no further than anthos and to learn
more about this managed platform
and how it can help you check out the
anthos 101 learning series
all anthos all in one spot apis play a
critical role
in helping software connect and
communicate as well as making the lives
of developers
a little easier and to make it easier
for you to use them
we've compiled a list of our most
popular posts
head over to the blog for more if you
want to read more about any of these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you